well that was weird yeah we just
finished over the garden wall and now it
makes sense
I know I mean I'm so confused before but
then when you get to that ending the
last few episodes just like got it
nailed it it's all about the lies yep
beautiful eyes yeah we have no idea what
that was about
um I liked it oh I didn't oh good I want
this I need to own it I mean we're
watching it on Amazon but I know we need
this I'm like I need it yeah I need a
copy of this yeah so we should talk
about where it goes they of course come
across other strange misadventures and
stuff and then we get the shovel on
twist it was during current times no I
disorder you know like the seventies
yeah I don't even think they look like
the 80s that look like the 7 you know
what I mean not in like whatever which
burning times or whatever they were kind
of indicating it took place and um so
I'll they did more than just burn
witches background okay they imprisoned
debtors okay there's that
um but yeah so these two kids you know
they go and uh I'm guessin easier so you
take over uh yeah so the two kids go and
find a an old abandoned Shack there
seems to be a ton of these around
sittin there's no room in our camp okay
they meet up with this like sort of
scullery one chair I don't know what
would you say like milkmaid type girl
who's like hey look out you can't be in
here otherwise auntie whispers we'll get
you with great name they mediate like oh
it's like that day the second she said
auntie whispers everything whoo I was
like that just sounds bad um and so yeah
they hide in a basket of turtles back
Turtles black turtles and then auntie
whispers comes in looking a hell of a
lot like uh yeah bug was a Baba Yaga or
what why am i blanking on her name
something lava uh you Baba you by uh
yeah from spirited away and uh yeah
uh through a comedy of errors um
basically they tried to trick you Baba
lock themselves in a room with the
milkmaid and then this whole time the
you Bob has been ringing this Bell air I
should say auntie whispers been ringing
this Bell tells the girl the pokémons
you wondering if she's like Pacifica
Northwest yes or something um and so
they locked themselves away and you Bob
was just like I don't have the Bell and
the kids are like aha so we've saved
urns like no you don't get it she's out
of her mind she's gonna kill you and the
next thing you know it's shitting bricks
time cuz like the girl just good I can't
even just in just be besties teefin big
eyes and it it was scary it was very
scary if we go through every light cuz
we watch like four of these if
everyone's gonna be I was just gonna say
like three sentences in like the last
couple have to say you like you idiots
nice okay and in comes fine that you
tell the fucking story okay so whatever
they get her back to normal
hey I guess they banished the spirit
away with the Bell which are wondering
why the auntie didn't do that but I
think the auntie was enjoying having a
surf and struggling but then they make
her kind of good at the end that was a
little confusing uh imagine some
confusing in this special but then they
go and uh the brother is goofing off too
much he goes into his dreamland and he
comes across the least and the Beast
wants to take him and turn him into this
kind of wood that keeps the lantern yeah
the lantern lit that the woodsman has
had and we find out that apparently the
spirit of his daughter is in the lantern
but then it's discovered that actually
the Beast needs the lantern lit so that
he can stay alive and that the spear the
daughter is probably never even in there
and there's a flashback that you forgot
to mention you ass well I'm just doing
the cliff note version here and we find
out yes this isn't even a small garden
wall and we go to but we also find out
that
worked and his brother they were who
confusing he says you know it's it's you
and your dad which stepbrothers maybe I
found out like I confusing too so we
found maybe least if maybe it's like
whenever our parents like R upset at us
and all of a sudden became you know what
your son yeah baby yeah that's right
when you're in trouble it's the when
parents you know when their kids are in
trouble it's ever you know what our son
did it's you know what your son yeah
what your daughter did suddenly like the
person talking completely disowns yeah
clearly got this from you um so he's
trying to impress this girl with this
cassette and they gets really
embarrassed it doesn't want her to hear
it and then they fall into pretty much
this lake and we're both thinking the
same thing so like is this all purgatory
are they dead is this the afterlife uh
but then they defeat the beast or the
woods my should say defeat appease by
blowing out the lantern they wake up
that they get the bird or the yeah gets
the bird the scissors so that they can
be turned back to normal and yeah then
they wake up and he gets along with the
girl and it's like oh and here's what
happened all the other over the garden
wall characters and like again the whole
time the Frog says it's beautiful lies
so they're probably dead I'm only saying
they're in the river maybe I mean you
see where they really hit by the train
in the flash bag that was kind of my
thought yeah that was my first thought
uh but they wake up you know in the
river too so it's like
maybe use a dream I don't know um and it
just kind of stops uh and even the even
there is like ml of heavily after
everything's gonna blow up I'll put over
the garden wall like even he's like yeah
you don't really care about it you know
the drill
um you know the one thing I'm not get
like I totally understand all this or
what it's initially trying to do I mean
I I enjoy it a great deal let's
understand it's a bunch of folktales no
what I'm saying is that the one thing I
didn't get into and you kind of said to
I don't know if I liked them being in a
more contemporary time being in the 70s
or 80s or wherever they were I didn't
hate it
I'm just not sure after that episode
kind of like I don't know if I need yeah
why was it needed I mean the
explanations were cute for why they have
the costumes on and why he's got the
candy in his pocket I do well I'm an
elephant I mean that guy was great um
but yeah I don't know I'm trying to
think of a grimace I don't know if it
was nori yeah um you know me that wasn't
you were saying that like I guess the
guy that put this together wanted to be
even darker and then they had him
lightning yeah I guess the story goes is
supposed to be kind of like a big
Halloween special but he didn't quite
have a full narrative and then as
production went along you know things
change is you know you're working out
the kinks and uh yeah I guess it became
a little more lighthearted a little more
comedic but he still wanted scary
moments I thought there was scary moment
said that whole bit with the crazy
milkmaid and her being possessed and I
was like wow if I were a little kid I'd
be shitting bricks right now like I
would just look so but yeah I get like
some people out there just like well
it's Dante's Inferno and there's nods to
Dante's Inferno it is like but it's not
just its Dante's Inferno now like oh
brother or artha where it's like that's
obviously the Odyssey you know I it's
it's got a few allusions to Dante's
Inferno they start off lost in the woods
there is a Beatrice but Beatrice and
Virgil in Dante's Inferno
so only main characters but I get ya
brother but I guess and I guess Beatrice
being the guide is kind of like that I
guess there is a fairy if you want to go
with the steamboat with the frogs and
there is kind of a frozen lake at the
Aneta frozen lake but no surpise at the
end well I was gonna say yeah there's a
frozen lake in the story but there's
been feet the devil in Dante's Inferno I
don't remember that I don't think he did
I thought he like climbed off the devil
and then slid there was like a river of
forgetfulness or something and then he
emerged from the river and it's like
Easter and God and yeah and like that
that does kind of sound like this ending
to beau emerging from you know the lake
emerging
yeah emerging from the lake but in the
beginning of Dante's Inferno there was
like a three beast thing in people - god
it's like the beast but in this one the
beast is also like kind of Lucifer oh
yeah it's is it even Lucifer and you
can't really you don't really kill this
for it we said it remember in Dante's
Inferno and clearly we need to don't
take any I don't think any of these
really represent hardcore like the
circles of hell either they seem like
little they seem like American folktale
vignettes yeah so it I don't know I'm
not really it's not - yeah I'm sure he's
got nods to Dante's Inferno but it's not
like it's Dante's Inferno it no there's
like more in it than that um yeah you
know the one that I and it's so bizarre
this isn't one I like the most the one
out of all of them that I liked the most
was one that you could argue was the
biggest waste of time was when he was
dreaming and it's like the old 1920s
rated tens Villar Jeff opens the care
they took in recreating that old-school
United Artists sort of like early 30s a
kind of animation especially the
backgrounds that was amazing
um but yet what I liked about what I
liked about that episode too is that a
lot of it like I said cowling was her
vows and where the wild things are I
seem very much to let like kind of the
emotions of a seeing guy the way not
really the logic and that one scene the
most like that to suddenly have like you
know there's a scary thing coming but
then like you know the beautiful lady of
the clouds comes but only you can go not
the brother the brother is being taken
but it just seems like sort of like the
ups and downs of like a kid's emotions I
can just change on a whim sort of
directed that episode and I really like
that I sort of like going through those
just spontaneous like emotional changes
just with so much like those old
cartoons like those cartoons were like -
yeah yeah I mean we used to watch them
they used to rerun them on like
Nickelodeon and stuff and you know kids
networks back in the early 80s and yeah
it was like kind of nostalgic just
seeing that style of animation again I
haven't seen that like a spoof of that
done so well in a long time yeah well
especially a legacy something about like
the way the backgrounds were and they
were a little they were there a little
shadowy but a little grainy too and
there's always something is that even
though the brighter come another bright
and colorful mood the loose animation
and the sort of repetitive quality when
he's jumping over the little uh holes in
the clouds and you know the big bad
cloud got ordered ordered order of a
thunderstorm it just I all you needed
was kind of like the Popeye voice
attachment good gonna go get you let's
go the clapping sound like to just yeah
prefers like Bluto or but I think too
there's something about those old
cartoons I serve got it here too which I
really liked is that even though yes
they're bright and colorful and
everything's dancing is tough there's
kind of a creep value to them as well oh
yeah especially like there's a lot of a
bag family always like I don't quite
over exposing it a stuff like that don't
look like Campbell's Soup kids it's
weird yeah but I mean it's just
something about like it says they're
very they were more led by the emotion
like the bad guys are gonna be bullied
cartoons all had a nightmare fuel aspect
to it
in fact most American folk art which
this whole show is picking from pieces
of American folk art over the past like
hundred fifty years have a creep factor
to it if you've ever seen old Halloween
costumes oh yeah there you had like you
have not seen terror to like go look up
vintage Halloween costumes for like the
30s and 40s it's just uncomfortable yeah
they all look like something out of the
fucking purge or something like it's you
just looking at me just like wow that is
not the last thing I want to see
suspicious before I die um so yeah I
mean I guess no part of me was expecting
like any kind of explanation about what
this all is or where was leading to or
anything like that so it but like I said
something about what when they went to
the the 70s you know the more
contemporary time I guess I felt like oh
now we're kind of in a normal cartoon
yeah there's weird things but it's like
it's kind of just oh the boy wants to
impress the girl and oh we're gonna find
out it if he had oh you're okay and oh
they were gonna get away it's something
I did I didn't hate it but I was like I
did not feel that was needed yeah but I
did love the commentary and how
Halloween used to be more fun like did
you notice that the
so just like hey what are you doing
there kids ad just kidding yeah there's
this sense of like nobody gives a shit
whereas nowadays like hey Ronnie
ah just kidding hey Bala nowadays you
have to have like parental escorts to
leave the house like I'm like how did we
survive in the 80s like it's like
Halloween nowadays is like Dumbo like 4
p.m. I remember trick-or-treating at
night well remember they did lie they
made up that story about like you know
whatever the guys that put like razor
blades in the candy and like there has
never been a report of that so it's like
they had some bullshit back then - but
you're I know you're talking about where
it's like you got a trick or treat
whatever it at four or five o'clock or
three and I'm like why that's not that's
a Halloween some Hallows Eve not All
Hallows early afternoon yeah so no I
like that too
uh doesn't our children like veal but uh
the whole special I really like um like
I said that the only thing I couldn't
get into I didn't hate I just couldn't
get into it was the the more
contemporary time stuff I liked it well
enough cuz the biggest mistake the
biggest mistake would have been setting
it 2015 or fourteen or they're like post
millennium by setting it in the 70s you
still kind of had a feeling like this is
still sort of out of place at a time I
couldn't quite pinpoint I'm like alright
there's a tape recorder there says space
battle like I'm guessing mid to late 70s
like Star Wars ish but at first I
thought maybe is the 60s and I'm like
that looks like some of these like it
still has a girly girl bunny outfit kind
of hair like 70s or 60s like dress yeah
or something like that I'm thinking I'm
thinking 70s if there's if that's
supposed to be kind of Star Wars I'm
like 76 or something like yeah also is
come on what's at 75 or 77 I don't know
but leap mid to late 70s but uh yeah so
it's one of those things I wasn't like
oh this room did those the one thing
well it's like well this is now we're in
a normal cartoon like an old cartoon you
see anywhere on Cartoon Network which
Cartoon Network is still strange and
they show a lot of weird stuff so it's
not like there any of it is we're
complaining that looks like any other
normal show on Cartoon Network I guess
it's just a statement that we felt this
show really upped Cartoon Network's game
exponentially on the network I think
still does pretty well I'm
that's not a slam against Cartoon
Network I'm just like they've been doing
well and now the bar just again has been
so raised well it was such a this was
just so fascinating like I said I've
never really seen anything quite like
this there's definitely hints of like
you know a kind of adventure time and
stuff like that but it's like there's
anything quite quite this original uh
and it's such a wonderful breath of
fresh air that they would throw you know
this money at this very bizarre story
with this bizarre layout and I mean just
these little vignettes and what was it
over five nights or something like that
there's a little bit of a continuing
story but not really like I was telling
him when during that scene with the
dream sequence and stuff like that I
said you know if I was an animator on
this I would have no idea if this was
good you particularly the first couple
minutes of that scene with the little
angels wandering around and that we
represent the club okay if that's what
you are yeah I'm like I'm on a paycheck
but man this could be Batman Robin I'm
worried that I have no freaking idea
like this looks crazy um but at the same
time I do kind of like that it is a
special where it is hard to pinpoint
exactly what it is or what you clarify
it as like if I let's just tell someone
like in a sentence what it is it'd be
tricky not that can't be done but it
would be difficult to do you can't just
say oh it's weird and bizarre it's like
what else I'm like France Tippy's weird
and bizarre adventure time or something
it's like how it's like there's
something else on this journey it's like
a journey through American folklore it's
like Washington Irving like Rip Van
Winkle Sleepy Hollow it funeral folklore
especially feels like that um with
really didn't turn yourself on us I'm
sneeze yeah yeah I did not sneeze you
did not have some makeup quit even she's
right no sure um but yeah like
Washington Irving's stories you know as
I was mentioning last when scary stories
to tell in the dark those old American
folklore tales that were spooky and yeah
mixed with you know like nods to Dante's
Inferno ins yeah or Alice in Wonderland
all that stuff yet even like the old 20s
car - it just just anything kind of old
you know even the 70 somehow get in
there I guess oh and I will say it's a
lot of it seems to be also kind of based
on like faith and you know cuz he loses
hope and then the brother tries to save
him and then the older brother comes in
and tries to save him and then there's
like this the kids souls keep the
lantern alive and like I don't know I
guess if you want to make the argument
that's an allegory for the soul like
Dante's Inferno you could idea uh and
I'm not saying you can't make like
allegories or connections to something
or like find something deeper you say
like has aspects of like Dante's Inferno
and other things there I'm just not sure
if that was the reason for it existing
if anything I like a story more that
isn't just this is just blank you know I
like where it sites elements of this
elements of that sort come together and
create something kind of new that we
haven't seen yeah when people say like
oh I'm writing a Valentine to like
Dante's Inferno that's just Hollywood
code word for ripoff this seems more
than that you know this seems like
something we're just like I have a whole
bunch of ideas and vaguely like Dante's
Inferno like it that there's a
difference very very vaguely yeah yet I
still wouldn't call this like Dante's
Inferno for kids I know it doesn't sound
right it's just it's more than there's
one that I wouldn't recognized it I'm
like okay well these aren't pits of hell
like everybody seems to get a happy
ending at the end and it's really far
removed in a lot of ways it's just
there's little nods to it yeah so uh I
really liked it I liked that I can't
quite pinpoint what it is or how to
describe it or or any of that stuff but
I liked how it kept me intrigued the
whole time it wasn't like and joke this
is supposed to make you laugh or it's
supposed to make you think it's just
sort of this weird like just escape of
subconsciousness you know just like hey
you know just when you're kind of half
awake half asleep and you know this is
the kind of story that we're gonna tell
it's like why you're half awake half
asleep oh I know how to describe it it's
like myths beautiful lies
beautiful eyes uh so yeah a final
thought I'd say I want a sequel series
but I know how you go back so I know I
was amazing and I want the soundtrack
yeah so do I um I really like the music
this I would say sequel say I do like
yeah or may like what they do with
avatar like maybe like a spin-off or so
no you know I don't even want that I
just want the same people to do
something different because this was to
examine what's great and I'd love to see
what they do um you know like yeah the
Animaniacs to Tiny Toons and that's what
I like you know something this isn't a
sequel would recognize
you would recognize it as being the same
people even though it's kind of
different
yeah so uh good stuff and we'll see you
next time
watch it beautiful eyes beautiful